Avery Kim: Today’s focus: caching strategy for product page.
Noah Williams: Any blockers from last time?
Priya Singh: Let’s aim for a concrete owner and rollout plan.
Priya Singh: I think we split caching strategy for product page into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: Risk: accessibility gaps for caching strategy for product page.
Priya Singh: My take is we split caching strategy for product page into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: Action: write migration.
Avery Kim: Risk: flaky tests for caching strategy for product page.
Riley Chen: Action: set up dashboards.
Priya Singh: Infra-wise, We might need a migration.
Samira López: Action: book design review.
Jordan Patel: We’ll need QA test cases listed on caching strategy for product page.
Priya Singh: UX needs a final pass on caching strategy for product page.
Priya Singh: Let’s keep this within this sprint on caching strategy for product page.
Priya Singh: Risk: scope creep for caching strategy for product page.
Priya Singh: Risk: data migration for caching strategy for product page.
Jordan Patel: Coordinate with SRE for rollout on caching strategy for product page.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on caching strategy for product page; parallelize testing.
Priya Singh: I think we split caching strategy for product page into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: Action: create test plan.
Priya Singh: From QA perspective, Any risks we’re missing?.
Priya Singh: Infra-wise, Specifically for caching strategy for product page.
Priya Singh: I propose we split caching strategy for product page into two subtasks.
Samira López: From design side, We will stage it behind a feature flag.
Priya Singh: Action: book design review.
Jordan Patel: Risk: scope creep for caching strategy for product page.
Samira López: Infra-wise, Specifically for caching strategy for product page.
Riley Chen: I propose we split caching strategy for product page into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: Action: create test plan.
Priya Singh: Action: create test plan.
Priya Singh: Risk: flaky tests for caching strategy for product page.
Jordan Patel: I think we split caching strategy for product page into two subtasks.
Priya Singh: From design side, We can chunk work behind a ticket.
Priya Singh: I propose we split caching strategy for product page into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: Quick update on the scope on caching strategy for product page.
Jordan Patel: Infra-wise, Tests should cover unhappy paths.
Jordan Patel: I propose we split caching strategy for product page into two subtasks.
Samira López: From design side, Tests should cover unhappy paths.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on caching strategy for product page; ship a thin slice.
Avery Kim: I propose we split caching strategy for product page into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on caching strategy for product page; parallelize testing.
Jordan Patel: Risk: data migration for caching strategy for product page.
Priya Singh: We need to timebox the spike on caching strategy for product page.
Jordan Patel: Infra-wise, Tests should cover unhappy paths.
Noah Williams: Risk: accessibility gaps for caching strategy for product page.
Priya Singh: Risk: scope creep for caching strategy for product page.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on caching strategy for product page; parallelize testing.
Avery Kim: Okay, who can take ownership?
Noah Williams: Let’s finalize target date in Jira after this.
Avery Kim: We’ll review outcomes in the next standup.